are we also perpetuating Russian
stereotypes by our comments during this
session I believe we are Russian
stereotypes I'm Jean
I'm Russian I was born in Moscow my name
is Ben I was born in Russia
hi I'm Irina Marek's mom I grew up in a
former Soviet Union and I lived there
for 12 years recently and I'm Erik and I
lived with her in Russia for 12 years do
you feel bad when a Russian is portrayed
as a villain no I don't like when
non-russians play Russians because they
can't speak Russian and it comes out
some blah blah blah and it's ridiculous
all right now I'm gonna demonstrate what
actual Russian should sound Li at the
cocktail journalist who cheats the panem
Irish yeah Nietzsche one you put in my
which means I don't understand anything
because his Russian is awful so the
first character we're gonna watch is
Black Widow from The Avengers the
attackee ashido previous year I heard
mute accusation no Provost yet what the
[ __ ] is that I can actually understand
them the guy looks Russian in a tossed
salad the Giant yo this is like another
language I swear to God the fact that
he's struggling so much to say B
sentences and like slurring some of the
words makes it a lot weaker as a
character we put out don't let the ash
to occur see that so this line right
here she said do you really think I'm
pretty she said it in Russian the way I
hear that is I also just loved that the
Russian scene is a bunch of dudes tying
up a woman and like beating her to get
information did you ever have any mafia
experiences like this on my experience
yes they did
absolutely and dealt with a KGB how
accurate very similar you were in the
chair it's not kind of in the journal
but definitely very scary people yeah I
guess it's a good thing that we have an
example of a Russian who is a hero and
an Avenger this is Ivan Vanko from Iron
Man 2 just pause it right here this guy
does not look Russian at all very
accurate Russians will have a toothpick
for no reason in the round and then
sometimes pick it you were a lot alike
in a lot of ways the only difference
between you and I is that I the only
authentic Russian thing about this clip
is that this guy hasn't spoken yet also
the constant confused look I'm like
scouring everything and just being
confused by the universe feels very
Russian to me hilarious I have no idea
what [ __ ] just said it started with if
they kill me and then I don't know what
language the rest of that sentence was
in this was better than the Scarlett
Johansson I was gonna say Scarlett is
better than this at least I understood
her full sentence it was entertaining
not accurate but very entertaining
this is boris and Natasha from the
Bullwinkle show boris and Natasha
single-handedly ruined my childhood my
birth name in Russian is Boris and when
I came to America this show was popular
so I was always like hi my name is Boris
and I think Oh where's Natasha where's
the tush that's really original you
boris and Natasha I had to change my
name in English because of boris and
Natasha say the name boris and Natasha
when do they steal mattress Boris no
time like the president mutation Luke
we're coming to tano words looks like
the Danny DeVito which is every Russian
little pudgy father
why does Boris have to be so ugly he's
just like Quasimodo with a drinking
problem like who owns a jewelry store
nearby you probably looks like this
yes when it gets dark we grab mattress
and make a run for it
no that's a good accent I gotta say look
we're coming to toddle the accent was
very good they're very Russian I like
him that he sounds like my uncle he does
I agree this is Elizabeth and Philip
from the Americans we don't kill people
Jesus we wouldn't these are real stories
right like the Americans isn't based on
an exactly true story but spying is a
thing being in another country and
having to pretend to be American that's
a thing that happens and it's a really
interesting character
my dad instructed me specifically to not
be Russian whatsoever you have to be
American he said and I took that to
heart that's why we're in this tracksuit
we had a job to do it's the most
interesting take none of these
characters have Russian accents none of
these characters are alcoholics like
sitting there and like being macho and
not talking the Americans I think did a
very interesting job in portraying them
as anybody it could be anybody which is
scary it could be you and me now we're
watching red from Orange is the new
black maybe we should all get down on
our knees and lick it up I'm kidding
hey doubled our order of slop this month
we can cover it what's gotten into you
all right first of all this character is
my mom she's very good I think because I
know people like that every Russian guy
has somebody like this in their life
this is a pretty good Russian character
the accents okay sometimes there's a
mess it's a please notice how every
Russian character here's how you do it
you just take their smile and turn it
upside down and she also has this like
attitude that's like calm down I'm gonna
fix everything
yeah so she's definitely I think she was
well portrayed in terms of the strong
Russian woman yeah good job red that was
very accurate very interesting very fun
to watch we're watching rounders with
Teddy KGB top two pair
Teddy looks Russian you got to give him
that this is actually a really good
character
Malkovich he does a good job did you lay
that down that's good very good acting
very interesting to watch but again like
all the characters are kind of the same
yeah I don't know any Russian that eat
Oreos though yeah he's a unique Russian
Russians do not like warriors don't even
know what Oreos are but if they do they
wouldn't like them now we're gonna watch
Ivan Drago from rocky 4 I don't think
this would be offensive I think this
would be like actually if you're a
Russian you might want to be portrayed
like this means big he's strong he is
looks phenomenal
good looking Drago was like my ideal
vision of who I would be what I grew up
so this is I think kind of a a positive
portrayal of the with Russian but I
think people would root for Rocky right
so it makes him the villain what would
root for rocky because we're American
but if we were Russian would move for
Ivan I would be lying if I say that I
wasn't at least a little bit rooting for
Drago I was only rooting for Drago I
don't like Rocky
I think Russians are being depicted
better over time yeah we're better bad
guys now I just don't think it's the
most interesting what do you do
Russians sort of portrayed the spies in
this villains there's more it's not
offensive to me that the characters are
always the bad guys but at least speak
well enunciate the bad things you're
doing don't just your country to go
beats for Hollywood I think that maybe
they should have more roles for real
speaking Russians I think there are many
actors here who speak Russian look you
can do well and it would be I think more
interesting when you bring in more
authentic people they've
seeking ability industry not always the
same cases thank you mom thanks for
trying to get me a job
some director